We have. The UK Times is coming out and doing a profile piece,
so we're getting ready for that.
They're just gonna shadow us during the day
just as we make meals and be a mom and create content.
Just getting our makeup on,
Miss Flora and I.
We're also going to do a little family photo shoot out in the meadow.
They want me in, like,
a gown, huh?
My oregano.
Oregano.
I wonder how you doing today?
Say
hi, Pedro.
Gotta go get some ground beef and get it thined for lunch.
Was it Urban Monkey?
Yeah. Oh,
I know exactly that. Well,
because she just caps,
so she's really.
Oh, yeah.
Mabel, Mabel,
Mabel! And then back at me.
Nice. Hey,
non.
No.
Okay, so we
have done a lot today.
Kitchen stuff,
farm stuff. Boys are roping right now,
and I am going to get into a gown.
Kom Igjen!
Yeah!
This is awesome.
Oh, this is beautiful.
Everyone look at your dad.
Nice.